okay so I have a question for the lady
let's say you meet the perfect guy this
guy is handsome Rich successful all the
boxes that you want it to be checked
they're checked now he pays a hundred
percent of the bills so you can do what
you want you can work if you want to
work not work if you don't want to work
but he's paying for everything you're
happy like this is the happiest you've
ever been but one day you get a message
from a girl this girl met him randomly
at a bar on one of his away trip he took
her home and slept with her she provides
evidence of everything it happened but
it was just a one-time thing now you
love this guy this is the happiest
you've ever been and when you confront
him about it he apologizes he admits to
it he says he's very happy in the
relationship he loves you he wants to be
with you it was just a one-time thing
now mind you this guy is a one in a
million he can take care of you the rest
of his life do you look past it and try
to work through it or do you walk away
let me know in the comments